each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello thank you all for coming we are
very happy to have with a song hun kim
or song from MIT he's a postdoctoral
associate with mike ernst prior to that
he actually earned his PhD from UCSC
working with jim whitehead he's going to
talk to us today about some of his work
on predicting bugs by analyzing history
Thank You nochi thanks a lot for having
me today and I'm from Boston and the
postern is great place to live and one
small problem is for six months is very
cold so we have to stay inside so six
months is a really nice time to make us
some papers writing papers very
productive time of the year here sailor
is great it's very very nice later today
and also I'm baked led to be here so I'm
going to talk about the predicting box
by analyzing history so first of all why
I am so interested in predicting bugs so
usually yeah
sorry about that usually bugs has really
severe consequences for example in 1962
Martina one space probe had probe has a
problem in there controlling software
and then because of that it was a
keyboard diverting from the intended
path and then main control center has to
destroy the minor one space probe
similarly in 1982 actually in Soviet gas
pipeline in their control system there
is a small bug because of that inside
the pipeline they have a big fire Sophie
and then it has huge explosion this
explosion was recorded as the biggest
non-nuclear explosion in our entire
history because of software work
similarly 96 arraign five light machine
has bug inside so basically the problem
was they tried to convert the 32 bits
floating point number two integer and
then the number was overloaded and if it
cause of death at the 40 seconds obvious
launching and it was exploded so the
point here is bug has you really severe
consequences however the debugging
process is really boring and very
labor-intensive work I'm not sure about
you but most people hate debugging so
basically what I want to do is I want to
help developers to find the box in other
bands so that maybe they can have easier
time in their life then probably there
are many other ways to find the box but
why I'm going to use history so you take
exactly same reason why we are learning
human history so this great guy actual
charge has amazing code here it captures
the reason why we are learning human
history I think it's exactly the same
for software developers for example here
software developers who cannot learn
from of the history are doomed to repeat
it so basically ideas we have the same
mistake and again again and then I don't
want we don't
want to repeat it so the one over region
one over the way is basically be
analyzing history and then see if there
is the same mistake or not so in fact
the history can provide the more than
just the binding a box here let's say
what kind of informations are available
in history suppose or developers here
like Microsoft here working really hard
and every day they produce lots of data
how the code is basically raw data and
they create the specs emails and test
the cases will be put in many many datas
in everyday life and then one of my
research areas I mind those data and
turn those data to useful history
information from this is history
information we can get bunch of other
things for example we can understand the
software better see how they are
changing and then also we can use this
data for resource allocation which
module has more problem which model you
have to put more people and then also we
can see some change impact analysis
using the history when we change
something this and then in historical
data what has happened and also we can
do bacho prediction so basically what we
can do is previously received some bugs
inside of the history and they using
that data we can predict the future and
hopefully this data will be very useful
for developers and you can provide some
feedback to developers so today I'm
going to talk about the bubble
prediction part using a softy history so
before I get to my my tog and my idea
let's talk about our dream as a software
developers what actually we want to
achieve so supposed this big rectangle
here is our entire software system and
small dots inside is a module or file or
something and then our dream is this by
the way the green color is photo for
your module so what you won't have
entire program modules so it's working
perfect and it's very good this is our
dream but unfortunately this is not true
in most cases that Microsoft little
product but more
to add all software it's not true they
too have a lots of hidden box inside but
most often it's a hidden so we don't
know until they showed up so it's
problem some modules are buggy even
worse when we make a change suppose we
are we need to change this module which
was clean no bug inside and then when we
change you in through this bog here for
example we change and then turn into the
apology module so it happens in real
development cycle so basically I want to
help these two cases by introducing two
algorithms today I'm going to talk about
or two algorithms here so first one
called the changing classification the
basic idea is whenever we make it some
change in software we try to predict
either this change introduce a bug or
not the second algorithm is called a
bulk cash what you want to do is you
want to identify most vocal nodules in
all the bands so I'm going to talk about
these two algorithms and if you have any
questions feel free to interrupt me and
ask some occasions if you have so let's
talk about the change please speak Asian
first so 10 the classification the idea
is this suppose we have a development
the history or buche ad text area that
java and it has a live isn't one and we
made some change some people may change
it goes to live isn't too and division
three and then maybe as a developer
maybe we need another change right so
some people gave us new specification or
my boss said you you made some change
here so i made some change and now it
turns to review them for and always as a
developer my question was did I just
introduced a bug in this change or not
so this is the most common kitchen I had
so basically change the classification
one actually will answer these questions
either you in through this bug or not
why this is important why knowing this
is important so what
going to happen if if we know that a
change is likely to introduce a bug
first of all what you can do is you can
review this limited the code very
carefully because the change you made is
just it's very very pressure on you made
a change in five minutes ago it's not
likely you change the up some changes in
a month ago or a year ago you have no
idea about the changes you just amazed a
change you can definitely see what is
the problem if there is a problem but if
you want you can add more additional QA
efforts like learning more tenses and
then somewhere our inspections and so on
so I think knowing if a change you will
introduce a bug or not is very important
the problem so here is the overall or
ideal over approach or how we do that so
from the history what you can do is we
can extract some change in the window we
can figure out if this change it was
buggy change or not so also we can get
another example it's a clean change we
can extract the room change also we can
have another changes lots of changes
from history and they will feed those
changes into motion learner and I
basically try to understand what's going
on there and then after that if you have
some unknown change maybe you made one
change so it's a living entravision n
plus 1 can we ask machine learner what
is it is a either buggy or clean this is
over or approach orbit change the
classification and click summary of the
results so after heavy have enough data
what you can do is you can classify all
changes as a buggy or clean with a
seventy percent of recall and
ninety-four percent of precision so I'm
going to talk about what is recall what
it's pretty soon later on but the basic
idea is as soon as we said it's a buggy
the ninety percent it's really buggy
seventy percent recall means we can
capture bar about seventy percent ago we
still miss seventy percent thirty
percent of the box we still can capture
seventy percent so I'm going to show you
how we achieve this high precision and
recall
so push the job we have to do is we have
to expect some historical data and then
we have to label it changes either this
is clean change or buggy change so again
suppose we have a history data over the
same file to edit text area and then now
because revision 1 and hundred 101 102
so let's take a look 101 and 102 closely
here we map this one as a ridah bug
actually took there's a method called
set text with a special character tab
and then they fixed by adding insert tab
so the problem here is a set text
actually working pretty well this is Cle
program they try to print out some text
in in graphical environment and then it
works pretty well but if you feel the
special character tab set text is now
working so they found the problem and
then they fixed by introduce new method
called insert tab rate data special care
over the tab and then print out the tab
so how do i how did I find this fixed so
basically what I did is by looking some
change logs inside here so most open
source we are actually looking at the
Edit open source project here and most
open source has very strong guideline
about the change logs so especially they
try to fix some bug that is supposed to
leave messages like this they said I
fixed the bug something something and
then what we do is we have a link
between the change logs and Pogo
reportedly visit the burglary potency
this is really bug not a future
arrangement or so on and they remarked
this one as a fixed so again this is
when the bug was fixed it's not the bug
was introduced into the system so what
you want to see is actually here a
little bit carefully and then we we try
to understand when those set text was
introduced into the system and they
remarked toss point as a buggy change in
order to see that why we have to do is
we had to track each lines of this Libby
301 and then see when those line was
introduced into the system so we
it developer some algorithm to check
line changes so currently we are
interested in ribbit 101 so we go back
and go back and go back and then see
which line was added when so finally
what we get is called the line origins
for example here like no one was
introduced in Lebanon 12 and nothing has
been changed line three was introduced
to nine living in 23 and so and so we
try to understand when those lines are
added into the system so after that
let's get back to the example after that
what it figured is this set text was
introduced in revision 23 nice to delete
it wondering to line success just
looking at your example on the lines
move on so do you keep track of their
new location also she only uses for a
selenium the question was about the
deletion so that's really good kitchen
by deleting something if we introduce a
bug or if we pick some bug we lose that
kind of information so there is some
certain category that that we cannot
catch or we can define some bug into
reducing changes although all the times
so we miss some yeah I'm going to talk
about a little bit more what kind of
changes we are going to miss so anyway
here we find out livid on 23 and
reintroduce this this set text to the
tab and then we mock this change as bug
change so that has a good question here
and then when you eat a little something
and they we fix the problem then
basically we lose the information and
also another problem is we had a two
files here and then by changing
something here we introduce park in
different file actually there is some
dependencies but in this case also we
don't have you know the good way to
identify real cause and real problems
but still this method is very good so
using this labeling mechanism we can
label for example leave it on 22-23 as a
buggy and let's say we spawned another
problem here and then we mark it as a
buggy and
the rest week we mark as clean so we
introduced this okay go ahead so when
okay so when you have a revision that
fixes about okay the lines that got
replaced they come from many different
provisions right they could have been
contributed over time from any different
version right do you mark all of those
we mark all over them but we try to see
the last two changes as a buggy so
that's another good question maybe there
is some syntactical change right so
suppose the the set X the table was
introduced but later on they change the
only white space right then maybe we can
we didn't find the original source of
the bug maybe you can check the last
change which is white space changes
right or some formatting changes but our
program is smart enough to ignore all
whitespace changes and indentation
permitting changes so try to identify
the original problem as well as accurate
as we can so we manually actually
identified about 200 revisions manually
see which those label we manually
inspect those labels and then see there
are really iboga changes in turns out it
turns out about the ninety-five percent
of marking was correct about five
percent is not correct due to the some
deletion of the changes or some in
dependencies between changes but still
we believe it's very accurate and we
publish this algorithm limey a sable and
then at least more than three papers
actually using this algorithm or try to
improve this algorithms slightly better
other changes that you marked as bug you
were actually because of the body
changes did you actually did you just
read them all yeah we read home how many
go under its ponder the changes 200 the
cases one file for a whole bunch of
files or her different projects only we
looking at the one project change it
here and then from there the revisions
of all files to under the file changes
as soon as we mark as buggy we because
actually we few people in our lab access
they have a more than five years of
experience of rye
program in Java so definitely we are not
domain expert over the program but has
some knowledge of what is the bog and
where was the problem and then carefully
read the change logs and bug report and
then try to make sure either this change
is really buggy and then we found out
about ninety-five percent are reasonably
we marked correctly that's what we found
but it's a very subjective experiment
clean clean clean just means millions of
impound yeah yes Yeah Yeah right right
that's why I'm here right they we are
apply this algorithm for the Apple
software in the indie pooh and the apple
software has like a much better marking
or bug fixes then open source software
basically table full like a processes if
we're able they found the book they have
to go some sort of procedures right and
then they leave special mark so in that
case we we get more accurate marking
okay so so much do you need to change
your machine is it there yet but this is
only marking stage how much we need a
data is we found out about 500 changes
if you have more than 500 the changes we
have been a reasonable result about the
seventeen ninety percent recall and
precision so we definitely needed some
sort of initial set of data so let's say
we just start the new project today and
then we have no history and definitely
we cannot use this technique and so when
in enter jets will call with the
constant screaming for cabin has
replaced by a special one insert tab but
right it's called variables which one
and put wanting to be with that dental
pain swear the sword is going to set up
a tab and at that point and both pops up
with a different way uh yeah it's
possible Skinner I'm sorry i I'm not
sure I understand the kitchen correct if
there's a variable yeah maybe that you
put your called insert percept X of the
tab to do you had to indent so far on
this tape another fine cocking love
letter and somebody wrote gets put a tab
in it and we call it same test then with
the 37th character of this line and it's
a tab and go to the towel um I'm sure
Taking Back on Bob's align one that
strikes without changes in back right
right yeah we taking care of with all
the former changes as well so it's not
really little care that happened metab
cup concert richly now run
time-dependent will be processed
properly I guess if you have these tabs
it's a trap in fixed car trips me like
if your string you print them I mean you
have to be careful with the tab and then
the blank space sometimes like space to
matter respect the program semantics
that awesome um right even if it is
inside the quotation we don't remove any
space inside the quotation but the other
things I think it's a feel free to
remove spaces in the program that's
fully safe but here this is a great
example as soon as you see set text and
/ tab inside this kind of bug and and
then in the history actually one guy
found out the problem and they fixed it
and until other guys actually came into
the maybe new developer work another
part and then they didn't know about the
knowledge and then they introduced the
same bug two more times enjoy it
development history so this
great example yeah is that answer your
question or maybe you can talk about in
the offline yeah it's great later about
like the seventy percent like course
without bugs that you also going to
address that there right yeah yeah right
now week we can label it changes as
either clean or buggy and the next stop
we have to do is we have to restrict
some features from change what kind of
pictures you can extract so suppose we
have a change here revision 10 and
division 11 so obviously in change there
is some textural changes inside so we
can expect some textual information and
another thing we can think of is some
metadata so basically who made this
change and then when this change was
happening actually is either on early
morning or later afternoon or monday or
saturday or something like that sense
okay done um typically a single check-in
involves more than one change honey even
if the developers are careful about
labeling all of the bugs that are fixing
in a single champion how do you
associate bug with a particular Delta
learn files right first of all we take
single change as a one instance we don't
actually see all changes sets together
with we feel with a single change at a
time also with we are very selective and
we do experiment so for example ugh I
said I fix the Bob and then he commits
hundreds of files then it's kind of a
trouble right but in our open source for
the key we'll take a look at mostly they
are either committed one or two files at
a time so we try to select those
projects that was the question I was
asked as asking Lee frequently in East
around here maybe not some source
project when people do a check-in facing
several different problems at the same
time and so the change lawd reversal on
where they will save somebody such and
such
absorption right in the case we don't
have really good way to distinguish
which box or a fixed in in which the
beach Delta so we just I just assume
that all change old old Delta in those
commits are all fixed changes that's why
we assumed what you say your version
yeah it as you mentioned there may be in
one commits developer can fix ten
problems right and then edit the result
or maybe he has 22 house so the best
ways if you can map it in problem one
Delta 2 3 and then problem 2 Delta six
seven this is a kind of ideal situation
but we don't have any data like that so
what we did is my assumption is if the
change log says it's a fixed bug and pub
numbers then all change associated with
those chains are marked as a fix and
then we see windows fixed lines actually
wore introduced and the remark exchange
pocket changes that's only oh that's our
assumption we didn't have any way to
distinguish two changes new market
changes but your claim is that with
respect to a particular bug number or is
that just it caused a bug and you don't
actually care which ah we don't actually
care of each kind of bugs or stability
or something as soon as they Marcus fix
you yeah the check-in fix ten bucks
because all of those fixes right fix
some bug so it's just the notion that it
fixes a bug is good enough for this
analysis right right thank you yeah is
it one bit of information this this
check in is clean this check in is babby
or instead try and stay you know this is
clean this is I believe this we don't
know which so currently we just have a
we just mark the buggy changes first all
the rest we assume that there's no bug
which is not really true but yeah well
but in our so here's another reason why
we can assume that a little bit in
comfortable ways so also i did some star
in how long it will take it to find the
box it turns out about a one-year to six
months they can find the box but here we
use the like about 10 years of history
and then because of that reason we use
the first part of the history so that
means most bug will be a lady they found
so that's kind of a little bit i'm not
sure if you are come to with that but
I'm little bit comfortable to use that
kind of data and then I assume that most
of bugs actually what actually are found
okay and then yeah for the futures we
texture format and then some metadata so
in summary over Peters we used to text
the features from program text and
deltas and variables and file ends and
change locks also software has a complex
the matrix basically it gives us how
complex this software or this method is
this valley is and we use the complexity
metrics because we have two changes we
can see either this changes goes to more
complex way or less complex away so we
also use the complex matrix Delta and
then a few change in varadero right like
author and then data date and time over
changes so using this mechanism what we
can do is from historical data
historical changes we can exert the
bunch of vectors like this and then we
have labels it is labels indicates
either this change is clean or a pocket
change so we extract about 20,000
features of single change now assistance
to like a pretty standard machine
learning problem set so here we use the
machine learning technique using
bayesian net and svm you try to train
this data so after that if we have a new
change what we do is also we accept some
some features from New change and we try
to predict either this is pocket change
or clean change and how we evaluate this
so in order to evaluate we need a
training set and paste the set so we use
the 10 called for
10-fold cross-validation for that and we
try to get precision and recall which is
the de facto standard to measure the
performance so here is the thing so we
can predict either this changes well
you're clean and the impact we know the
real label so we can compare with the
real label in this case it was correct
our prediction so this from this
prediction we have a four outcomes from
this prediction basically the suppose
this is real buggy and clean change and
this is our prediction then what you can
get is we can predict real buggy changes
as a buggy and also you can predict real
clean as clean which is correct changes
and compulsorily you can predict buggy
as a clean or clean as a buggy so using
these phone numbers while you can
compute its precision here precision
basically means all box here either we
are predicted correctly or not correctly
sorry pretty shitty means whenever we
said it's a bug our predictor says it's
a bug and how many of those are really
bad so this is precision means recall no
matter how he predicts the billboard how
many you can catch so recommends input
there are hundred the bug and then how
many you can catch is recall this is we
predict as a buggy then how many are
really buggy this is precision so after
we compute this performance what we did
is some pizza selection algorithm
applied some future selection algorithm
pieces are called a peg world raping
approach the basic ideas we start with a
whole set of features and each iteration
will remove ten percent of features
using ok gain ratio and then we complete
the performance and an end of the day we
found the best to set over features and
we unfortunately we don't have any a
real easy way to access close a project
so we used a lot of open source project
including Apache Eclipse and subversion
and modular and then we try to get some
recall and precision
but this is the result so I think this
is something remarkable here if you see
the are let's say which one we like
eclipse you like eclipse I guess and
eclipse the first bar indicates recall
the second bar indicates precision here
precision is almost almost one hundred
percent which means whenever we said
this change is likely to introduce the
park one hundred percent was sure and
then the recall is not very high it's
about 70 more than seventy percent so
that means we still miss some bugs but
it's good so every G recall president is
about the Ayatollah people so 74 94 94
percent every G recall and precision
search your system sign that there are
some pretty simple features that then
describe the capture and characterize
the vast majority of products that are
out there and yet when I hear developers
talk about bugs it's it's a deep
conversation it's never a simple thing
it's never business value that so that's
that's clean you know it's way more
nuanced ones are really complicated so
so having trouble believing that you
know between them that bugs can be
characterized this kind of glennley
right you hit a good point if there is a
new book came in and then we have no way
to predict that correctly because we
never seen the kind of bug before that's
why the recall it's pretty early below
so in thirty percent to what we miss
maybe it's a new bug we never seen but
the portal example I gave you the stat
text with a special cake the tab
whenever we set up we see the the post
patterns we can say it's a buggy and
then that's a why we have a little bit
high precision so we saw some bulky
problem before and then as soon as we
see that we can predict it as a buggy so
it's the same as it's also it so you
have not already know this this is a
binary predictor
not really we provide you give you some
comprehensive examples right this is
finally I can say either could or not
it's a very easy prediction also let's
say you are working for a project for
five years and then you know the old
history of the of the software
development and then you understand the
system of so many cases just let me
finish this one and then I'll get to get
you and then you have knowledge about
the orbiters of the software named
suddenly new guy came in and he made
some change then it's all like a senior
developer maybe you can give some idea
this is good change or not immediately
right so basically I want to capture
that kind of knowledge using this
technique okay so is this for all the
versions of each piece of software that
you dream so we we we tried only first
the top 1000 revisions for this
experiment because of the reason that we
couldn't find all the bugs in the photo
for the current version so we gave them
some time to find the box what's the
difference between the training seven
centuries for evaluating so currently we
use the tent of folder cross-validation
basically we chop we get in we get the
instances changes and there is just to
select the top we put in the ten paper
and fold and they reused line fold as a
training and then one fold as a testing
but also we did some experiment with the
which is called online or incremental
learning basically we used first one to
end may be done protesting for the
training and then the n plus 1 as a as
testing and then we get a very similar
result so one of the reason why you use
the ten fold clothes validation is we
try to identify some more important
features and less important the feature
to understand why people make the same
mistake and what kind of features are
the dominant want to predict the box
okay I have two questions one video into
this you'll tell swisher the future
actually turned out to be interesting
and then the second one is for the
thousand check-ins for each of these
different projects that you looked at
did it matter what time period those
thousand changes were like and where
they were with respect to a product
release okay so let me get the first
occasion what is the most important
features so this is actually very
interesting thing to see we dealing with
about 20,000 features I think number not
number one but one of the top important
features are authors which who actually
made the change is important one and
another one we found is like some
special condition so if you use each
condition with a special variable we are
making more bugs because maybe the
variable has maybe maybes people and
have hard time to understand the
variable the cement ago variable
correctly so when every day is diff
maybe they forget something it's kind of
stuff and this and so on in the second
kitchen I'm sorry I forget the second
occasion was um you selected 1000
jackings for each of these projects that
could have been any time during in the
history of the project you know before
some points to present did it matter
whether those styles and check-ins
overlapped with a product release and
could it be different before after a
release of a version of the product ah
yeah that's the really good kitchen but
unfortunately in our open source when we
are looking at the history we didn't
actually take account for the lead point
or major revision or something so we
just take all changes it's just a simple
change so we don't have any data like
that I think it's very interesting to
see if any major release will affect
this kind of result thank you so for
each of these sound checking how many of
them are very right about twenty to
thirty percent are buggy it's a really
good kitchen since this is binary
classification maybe you can say all 20
spoke you're all changes may be randomly
we can say and how much we can achieve
the precision
maybe recall in terms of recall we
cannot achieve hundred percent recall by
predicting all changes as a buggy but
precision we cannot do better than
twenty thirty percent of precision ok
this is ninety one hundred percent
precision it's much better these
projects do you test it on the entire
project moving test on one of the fire
in the project we have read it offers
the 1000 changes no matter what fire is
yes we didn't we didn't take a look of a
kind about training on the history of
one fire you can Stewart Addison the
machine to other files oh that's
actually another interesting point if
you can run some specific poke
appearance in different files we didn't
actually do that but we collect all
changes from 1500 all product from from
all project yeah all correct and one
product but seems like it's a good idea
to want to try to understand the common
bug patterns of each single files I
think it's oh yeah but we didn't do that
currently we we collect all changes from
one project no matter what kind of
valdaire change who changes 20,000
slides isolating we get about the 4,000
features turns out the best assets of
the features it's very fitting project
and project trends the feature selection
work was very listened to work about a
month ago tomato go so we didn't
actually you're in the process of
understanding to selected the pitchers
and then I don't have answers yet it's
good kitchen anyway wow it's a lots of
kitchen thanks a lot okay we compared
with our approach with others so in 2007
musi not at all actually they introduced
on technique that they use a spam
filtering program and try to identify
either this changed or this file is
buggy or not
by training that and enter a pest three
call invest the precision is about the
51 259 their best ones and then in an
hour so no at all these are change
classification is similar to ours and
they extract the only textual method
textual features from source code and
therapists the precision recall is about
fifty nine percent in our case in our
average II recall precision is stable
into ninety-four percent sister papers
actually you don't have really pinchy
mark but here and here we have with the
same set of a project like eclipse we do
have same but we have a like a third 12
open source project put the 82 only 2
334 something so we are like a superset
over there I experiment always the
variance sorry I once again what was the
brains in across the benchmarks in terms
of the 70 90 I guess you showed you
showed the right right but how different
for each project I think of one of them
they usually eclipse parade improve- our
eclipses of our performance than
everything so it's a better than average
our Eclipse they use the Eclipse Farish
mean you're consuming the only
legitimate versions of names
yeah then we'll be better than a breeze
yes they printed yeah thanks yeah okay
so in summary of the tentacle
ossification use the machine learning
algorithm at the training we can predict
about the seventy percent recall and
ninety-four percent the precision of
either change is clean or buggy I think
this is really are applicable in real
development process for example
developer may be making some changes
commit to the SCM system and as soon as
the same get some tear changes while you
can do is you can run through these
analysis and send some feedback if we
think it's a little buggy change also
maybe you can embed this thing to the
editor level like eclipse or Visual
Studio and then whenever we monitoring
some changes and then whenever we feel
like this change goes to will likely
into this some box maybe you can change
them background the color slightly and
something and currently yahoo and Apple
are interested in using this technique
in they are developing the process
hopefully Microsoft will be the same
we'll see the next I will talk about the
bulk cash algorithm again the poor cash
what I want to do is I want to solve
this problem so some modules are more
vulgar than idle modules so I want to
identify those modules in other bands so
why this is important so because always
our money and time is limited so we want
to identify which file we should focus
on first so I've been told that in
windows 2003 team here and they have a
binary list called escrow list and
manually they maintain those escrow list
and the as soon as developer make some
changes on those binaries they have to
go some certain level of code inspection
they manually either manually maintain
those lists why they manually maintain
those lists why did didn't go too deep
analysis for all binaries because they
have always limited time so they want to
do
care for most vulgar pollen or binaries
but here is the same the idea is you
want to maintain orient won't identify
those files automatic way so this is
kind of a hot area in our research so a
lot of people try to identify where are
the box so few findings people said in
new files as soon as you create a new
file then we'll have more bugs in it and
then other people find out here and in
modify the files if you have a if you
change the file then you will have a bug
and Ho Chi Minh mine actually found
another interesting thing the spatial
locality we've we found the bug in here
in the nearby files either by coal
relationship or code change the
relationship will have a bug and
Austrian they're all they found out that
a temporal locality so we fix the bug
well you think you fix the bug but in
fact there are more bugs inside of those
files so it's kind of kind of temporal
locality so our solution is basically we
want to want to have a list again and
then also dynamically I want to audit
dynamically update the list as a we
project goes on and also I want to use
the previous foundings Twitter so our
idea is using cash so basically we have
a list of area we called it cash
hopefully we will have most welcome full
profiles inside of the cash so here is
the kick summary of the poor cash so ten
percent of all cash means usually we
hold only ten percent on file inside of
our list and those ten percenter file
using those ten percent we can predict
about 73 to ninety-five percent Oh box
so if you see that if you monitoring
only ten percent you can catch about
eighty percent of bugs it's a good good
deal I think so how we do that this is
high-level overview of the birdcage
operation so suppose we have all files
in here is the system each start here
indicate a single file so first of all
we have an area called cash the list so
mostly we have a ten percent of the
entire system
and as soon as the one we found the bug
inside of the file and then here our
cash list is empty so we didn't print it
correctly and then in this case we load
this file into the cash so we believe
those piles will help another bug soon
so we load it when you load this file
not only this file we also look around
nearby of files and they reload them all
together here in our experiment nearby
means code changes we load into the
cache and after that we believe the list
files in the cage we believe that there
are most folk important files and after
a while we believe some files in there
is not any longer dangerous we basically
replace this is high-level view of the
ball cash I'll give you some example
here supposed to behave of cache sizes
on it too and this is development the
history so as time goes on we will have
you will see some changes and some
changes with the bug fix here I say
let's go here we are we have a file
change it's not a bug it's a clean
change so it so it's good and then we
clean change and then now we have a sea
of exchange so in this case what
happened was so we our our list was
empty so that means we didn't predict
there is a bug in C file so we missed it
so basically you want how we missed it
first and they won't load you see inside
of the cash this is the basic operation
so here how we update the cache so well
my name is something that is bad cash or
two like a developer tool or is this
just a program you like to run or Jesus
algorithm yeah all right thanks ah if
there it is a mystery just the load to
miss the file into the cache simple and
not only this file we also load some
nearby files here again mirror by ms
code change so here we want to load see
into our cash then we compute how many
files are changing the Whittlesea hey be
na + p
see and so on so in this case the paypal
has been changed the most with the sea
so we believe the P is the nearby file
and they reload see and be at the same
time because we believe he is the most
close one and then we move along next we
have a change of the sea in this case we
are very lucky because we already
predicted see you will have bulk and
then indeed they have bugs so in this
case it's hit our prediction was correct
and then we go on a just a change and
there is another good log here speed
another hit so it's good maybe move
along and then I now have a bug we
missed it because a was not in the list
so here we want to load a into the
system so the problem here is we don't
have enough space so we have to decide
which one we should be replaced so you
come up with some few heuristics first
of all called a radio and the second one
is called change the last one called but
basically we see the metrics of each
file and then we decide which one we
should replace so suppose the Polka
means we see how many bugs in each file
and then we replace the list frequent
tippex suppose we are using the park as
our only play some of the policy and
what we see it's like a CN be either one
of these will be replaced and there is a
number of bugs and then we decide to
replace B because it appears only one
bug and after that we have a see an a in
our list so we believe the cna will be
the most work of run files for not put
the next two changes so this is how
about case you work and then how we
evaluate how this is you know predict
well or not well so idea is we used hit
rate here so basically how many bugs and
how many we create them correctly so in
this case error we had only fifty
percent of a hit rate it's clear
the time line above the line are those
check-ins or some other yes he's
chickens and this one is it's all
politics and photo fix is based on the
predictor you talking about previously
right teeny logs so you basically look
at the changelog for check-in and that
tells you whether there was a bugger not
know whether there was the word bug in
them right right so they're predicting
apoco pyxis which means a late there is
bug so if I understand correctly but
cash is a small subset of the total
system that is most likely to contain
bugs based on the revision history
you've seen so far yes and so therefore
that's probably where I want to spend my
dad testing budget or whatever right
right correct so for example we are
having only ten percent of the list and
if you can find the ninety percent of
puter bug in those ten percent it's
great right only or by monitoring ten
percent you can capture on twenty
percent is not good but it's the one of
the purpose of why we perform some
experiment here again we use the open
source project and then see what is the
proponents of the ball cash so the case
side is ten percent of all files and
then this is the result so basically
here so both and 73 / three percent to
about ninety five percent so that means
by having only ten percent of files we
can predict this much a bug right it's
not static analysis we actually had some
crab by ten to a hundred percent of a
cache and then percentage of the hit
rate we found that ten percent is the
most efficient percentage so it goes
twenty percent but we cannot double the
hit rate boo-yeah boo-yeah you have
industry could have misread
both your 2% looking for mr. instead of
history gonna hit rate ah miss radius
lagiglia 3 1 minus hit rate night
secretly when you're in eighty percent
similarly have mystery you can oh I see
yeah you can topple the hit rate but we
cannot also reduce the ha probably the
miss rate by increasing to any person so
we found the ten percent is the
efficient way but if if your budget
allows maybe you can monitor twenty
percent or five percent only 10 files
whatever you can decide oh gee presents
one you said you like from cash as the
ten percent one hundred percent what
about like point 01 / sent to one
percent I mean like bird less you know
if you got a project with my troubles in
the past class ten percent still a lot
right right so actually basically we
started from zero point two hundred
percent but the crepes looks like it
slowly goes up and in ten percent the
kind of maximum ten to twenty percent is
kind of maximum and then kind of steady
so that's why we see maybe so maybe to
have one percent maybe it's about twenty
percent thirty percent but still against
something but yeah I have a grape in sin
book where you talk about him rather
than precision and recall on those
chains right precision and Nicole is
important but uh I believe hit rate is
more territory to yeah this is giving a
false will make it right which is
precision right oh no in vain is me home
yeah febre this ring also what about
precision so here positives do you have
a less powerful right I think yeah this
good kitchen ah let's say we have a like
hunt some some modules inside over the
list but never one pile in the list
doesn't have any box it's kind of a post
positive right but we didn't actually
measured precision and Nicole I think
it's interesting to see president Nicole
yeah I haven't thought about that but
basic idea is we monitoring ten percent
how much bug we can capture by
monitoring ten percent of bugs later why
we came up a history and also in this
kind of work most people see that kind
of hit trade as their a propyl most
major so the goal one of goal is I want
to compare with this work with others oh
I will get to that point you introduce
three cash replacement strategies which
one is this okay so different project is
a slight different options some product
actually box will works better and some
some project LRU works better so
basically this we get to pass the
performance by changing the options it's
officially the block sizes also option
right how many we load the nearby ones
so it's a it's a pity but mostly the
pods problems better than adults number
of previous or the best of the best yes
this is the list but it's about the five
to ten percent difference if you use
some sort of a fix to set so the next
kind of goal is how we can find
automatically the bestest sets of
options how stable is the cash I mean is
it the case that three modules are just
always in the cash and those are the
three you should always test ignore the
others right we studied the how was kind
of a ton what is called in the in the
system there is something maybe turn out
later or something and then it turns out
like about the sixty percent of all
program he stays a very long time about
forty percent kind of in and out in and
out and stop yeah
so I'm so what's precision maybe a
better better way to think about it is
you want to look on cashing it in no I'm
not quite sure precision makes sense to
measure so basically precision here a
heat-resistant sounds very similar to
precision miss we predict 100 files in
our cage and how many of them are really
or in thymic ozone has a bug right so if
they're the book was found in size of
the cache we are happy but what we
didn't what we don't really measure is
like a false positive right so we
believe the file a will be will have a
blood tube ugh but maybe no bugs yes yes
nobody at all but we didn't actually
measure how many piles of this case
inside of the case we didn't matter that
yeah yeah but it's I think it's very
interesting to see how those kind of
phosphide you spend a lot of time but
we're going to find any bugs inside
right so lots of kitchens is I really
appreciate it yeah and then once I
compared with other work here our costco
at all they use the top 10% using or
reject the complex matrix i guess they
used overtake the complex matrix and
they identify top the top 10% of most
folk wrong and there they said 64% they
can catch using those top 10% hassan at
all on stage the top 10% using a number
of previous blog number of previous
changes and then they can identify forty
four to seven eight percent again we use
those seven open source project mostly
they use the one or two so we are like
super set up with them and then our ten
percent can 73 can predict 732
ninety-five percent so in summary
previous data with art ten percent can
predict 44 278 we can predict 73 to
ninety-five percent
so it's good using these two algorithms
I can I'm very comfortable to conclude
that on analyzing history is an
effective way to predict the box I
introduced the two successful algorithm
of change classification and podcast so
any applications i'm going to move to
the research overview and future work if
you don't have any kitchen about the
podcast on change classification when
you do this comparison with the other
existing work mm-hmm how many of those
other schemes are like a caching scheme
or trying to figure out in your rug cash
system what are the original
contributions from you here is the idea
of having a cache something that no one
else is tried before is it the cache
policy instead immune so it's a the
ideal behaving cash is very new
previously a lot of people try to
extract some metrics of Egypt files and
then either they they learn some linear
progression linear regression algorithm
and then get some vacation like like
this that's what they get and then and
they try to get some predictions but
here what cash is very simple algorithm
and they we understand the why those
files inside of the cash and its
objective indicators all bug or currency
modules we used all previous modules at
the same time but the end is very
complex model if you try to write the
equations or like these kinds of both
cash operation it's very complex but
intuitively we understand wise ok so you
it seems to me if you took your first
technique the prediction most on machine
learning you could select the modules
that have bugs in them just by watching
changelog and making the predictions say
yes you're in yes you're out yes you're
in yesterday would that not need you to
get a more accurate prediction of groups
ten percent of the files you should take
a look at just by counting the number of
occurrences that you right yeah that's a
good kitchen I think maybe combine this
two technique will read more better
accuracy but the first if you understand
the first changing classification our
target is not try to identify some bug
report on files or modules we take each
change individually so even though one
file may be a lot about huge files
changed so you ready isn't available
files being involved and change the
phone right right that's the true but
the one kind of a limitation of the
package kind of work even though we are
dealing with very vulgar perl modules
focus on files not all changes our bug
is some only some changes are buggy so
the first to work is try to identify
those kind of changes but the second
work is if you have like a limited
resource i'm going to show you some
examples of both cash how we use the
ball cash in real practice but we have
some limited resource which file or
which module we have to spend more time
than the podcast algorithm and then
either developers make larger changes
and then we'll see which change we have
to see more capable than changing
classification is the algorithm depend
Eliza's some common themes within these
two algorithms
okay so so my little joke all over
overall is a developer productivity I
really want to help developers and also
in the same time I want to have reliable
software so my current focuses is
predicting bugs but eventually I will
get into the all the my entire goal so
let's talk about what I did so far so I
have a like a tool big chunk of work
static world and dynamic world first of
all actually in static area is a history
mining so basically try to use history
to get some useful information so we
developed a tool called the Kenyan and
basically the extract all changes from
its same system sometimes it's okay ting
paid a premium system it's not really
easy so can you actually take care
automatically extract all changes and
then later on inside the canyon we
developed algorithm called how we how we
identify bug and reducing changes so we
developed an algorithm and then FSC last
year we developed algorithm called to
prioritize of warnings here is an
interesting work I think find the box or
some other static analysis tool can
provide some warnings of your source
code for example if you feed 1000 line
of source code to find the box find the
box basically give you 500 warnings so
so the problem is always we don't know
which one you should look because too
many possibilities so what I did using
history is we observe all warnings of
the hope those or tuning history and
then I I try to understand stand what's
going on there for example some warnings
appear into the history and then removed
very quickly and then the same type of
warning appeared and remove it very
quickly then maybe the warnings are
important the word people care about the
warnings but some warning stop appeared
and one year two years so stay in to the
system nobody cares maybe those folks
are really hard to find but more likely
people don't care about the warnings so
based on this assumption we try to
deprioritize
all the warnings and it turns out this
very effective way to do that yes
customers behavior and you're saying
customers prefer these type of warnings
or right to yes yeah but do our our yes
yes our assumption is that the people
are not using the bug finding tools in
their development history so it's not
really using that but still they can
find some certain kind of bug they do
care and they do list here so you try to
capture those kind of ratings and softly
understanding I try to understand how
signature are changing or pattern of the
program is changing and poke a
prediction part I give you three
examples of changing classification in
bulk cash today and another work is
called memories of bug fixes the basic
idea is so whenever there is a bug fix
we try to extract some syntactical
patterns of those fix in those bugs and
then as soon as we identify each change
as a buggy using change classification
then what we can do is we can provide
some examples not only saying this is
buggy we try to provide some examples
for example we already saw the set X to
the tab as marked as a buggy and then
turquoise funding pics is this would you
like to consider whenever people triton
through this set text will help in a
dynamic world actually i did a work
called the liquid the basic idea is
producing the crash or producing the
problem is a hard so i try to capture
all program running and then try to
reproduce the problem i'm going to talk
a little bit more about the recreation
later on so another work is called at
your day patch so what we did is
dynamically we run some program and try
to understand or try to learn some
invariants orbitals learning program and
if you save into database and then the
same instance is running and they maybe
get some virus or get attack or in bug
if we crash what we can see is where we
crash where the program crashed and then
we try to extract some invariants of
those crates the part and then see what
has it been different
if you find some differences in
invariance what you can do is you can
create a page automatically the Pacha
means basically we fix the invariants
and then we send the rest of the
instances and then as soon as they get
attack hopefully the pics worked out and
then it's not actually get the same a
table or get the same box we had our
test with the Firefox program and it
turns out it works pretty well and in
for the future work what I'm going to do
if I get a job so first the work is
trying to field some 20 classification
aware as same system change
classification actually had a few
problems first a big problem is the
source or labeling so whenever we label
we have some difficulties for example if
developers submit hundred change the
same time and then mark as a fixed and
we don't know which one is really picks
so in this same system what we can do it
as soon as developer make some changes
we can we can mark which change is
really quite funding to the really fix
or Lily box so you can identify real
bugs and real pics correctly and then as
soon as we have some commits we can send
some feedbacks to the developers another
one is a personal coding assistance so
author is one of the important features
to identify that this changes buggy or
clean so which means a lot of people or
the same people make the same mistakes
or same kind of mistake so I want to
understand what is my common error
patterns we learning by developers and
it provides a me some useful information
to each developers and then I can bind
more pork report and credit report here
and then also I found that some api's
people have paid much difficulties to
using some type of api's whenever they
use dead IPI they make lots of mistake
so I want to understand more why people
make more mistake using the API and then
you get some lessons in as soon as with
the same type of API we will give them
some information so last of all I want
to combine some complimentary technics
here I let us see a lot of people
here working on dynamic and Static
analyzed together and combining these
two things together in my case I can
combine with the mining technique and
static analysis technique and dynamic
analysis I'll give you a pretty example
of combining static and dynamic analysis
and also the example oak or podcast use
so I think you understand very well
what's the limitation of static and
dynamic analysis here static analysis
basically has very low overhead you
don't have to run program so basically
we read the source code or binary code
but the tester unfortunately has a very
high rate of false positives on the
other hand the dynamic analysis has very
low phosphide because we learn program
and as soon as they create your there is
some problem it's likely to real problem
but although it is really high most
times has a limitation so the idea is
why we don't when we combine these two
techniques together for example here
porque si is a little bit static
analysis technique try that to identify
most spoken for own files first and then
we craziest dynamic analysis part so I'm
going to show you some examples how we
combine these two techniques together by
introducing the courage first why I'm
working on licorice because the prudish
reproducing crazy is hard so most case
we need the correct configuration of the
client in order to reproduce sometimes
it also involves some non deterministic
packets so we there is no guarantee that
we can replace the problem but however
we have to reproduce the problem in
order to fix the bug and later the pics
we have to validate right we we fix it
correctly so you have to reproduce the
problem to validate and fix bugs so it's
a hard problem so we we introduce we
develop a tool called the Ukridge if
there is a subjective program what the
current node is we monitor each subject
the program each method calls inside of
the subjective program and then as soon
as subjective program crash what the
coach that is generates some unit test
cases so this unit test cases basically
reproduced
original problem so it works well and
then i'm using this request in my daily
development the process the only problem
one problem of the crash is it has a
very high performance orbit it's about
the 13 to sixty-four percent overhead
perhaps this is ok for research purposes
or maybe it's okay for debugging
purposes but apparently nobody want to
use this kind of 13 to sixty-four
percent is low microsoft word right they
don't want to use it so why this has
high proponents orbit with it up up all
things we can do like we did
immutability analysis point analysis we
try to save the minimal setup hope
method but still it's very high too why
because currently we monitor all modules
post this is motifs here we basically
licorice monitor all modules let's say
we have some sort of static analysis
tool like a podcast we can identify most
credible method in of the bands so you
can identify identify those method in
other bands and then we combine these
two things together we only monitor both
identify the ones suppose our ten
percent of module accounts for seventeen
percent or crashes like a ball cash then
what you can do is combine combine these
two we can learn the crazy plus forecast
with only one to sixty percent o ball
overhead but still we can you produce
every percent of crashes this is one
example of using combining two two
techniques together also you can pull up
using paul cash so people i summarize my
talk I like tank by two excellent
advisor from UCSC to my head and Mike
honest and MIT also idea I believe Lidge
work with many many talented authors I
really enjoyed and have lots of fun
working with them from MIT UCSC silent
University Iowa and industry in you top
and then definitely i'm eager to work
with new collaborators later just like
like you here and the summary so box has
really severe consequences and so really
we lose lots of money and even lives but
it still it's very hard and boring to
debug and i try to have developers by
predicting ball so the person one is 20
classification as soon as there is a
change i can say this change is likely
to introduce bug or not with very high
precision and second one is called a
bulk cash we can identify most blogger
prom modules using this algorithm and
for the future work i have a lot of work
to do and one example is combining some
static and dynamic analysis together
thank you very much any more questions
concerns and comments sure i hope my old
papers are online so you can download it
so yeah yeah i can give you the website
yeah i'm always loomis reviving the
educational lectures in finished concept
the recording is to be going on so no
prob that's not anymore kitchens thank
you thanks a lot yeah now we're finished